Every defense is associated with a disease and we'll now discuss some of the
diseases of exaggerated defenses.
This occurs because every defense is a benefit which is associated with some
costs and the costs are expressed when the defense is exaggerated or when it is
inappropriately deployed.
They range from mild things like itching and discomfort to death through organ
failure triggered by septic shock.
Okay,
so let's discuss immune defenses.
Quite inhalation and thrombosis,
tissue repair,
fuel reallocation and defense from starvation defenses against dehydration and
volume depletion,
avoidance of pathogens and avoidance of predators.
So immune defenses have diseases that are associated with them that include
autoimmunity,
allergy,
asthma,
septic shock,
anaphylaxis,
and other immunopathology is
there.
Increased incidents in the modern world indicates important contributions from
environmental factors.
The design issue is this,
the systems are devo designed with feed forward loops with positive feedback.
This is done to provide a rapid,
massive emergency response to infection that's associated with sepsis and with
toxins which leads to anaphylaxis.
But this creates these vulnerabilities to unmanageable runaway processes and
that is why things like sepsis and anaphylaxis hit so quickly and cause such
massive symptoms.
Sepsis that has a cascading series of failures in multiple organs.
It resembles the power failures in continental wide powerness.
The failure of one component increases the chance that the remaining components
will fail.
Yeah,
coagulation and thrombosis are both very good defensive reactions to wounding,
but they have associated diseases as well.
So they are defenses against vascular injury and they contain the risk of
embolism that leads to ischemia and infarction.
To be effective,
clotting has to be fast to avoid hemorrhage.
The speed is achieved by positive feedback that amplifies the response.
Positive feedback creates two kinds of vulnerabilities and excessive response
and fishes cycles.
Those inflammation promotes clotting leading to embolism and embolism promotes
inflammation,
producing,
cascading local circulatory failure.
So this is part of the gradual component of the development of heart disease.
Tissue repair
is he central.
We evolved stem cells to do it.
And the design of our tissue repair mechanisms contains vulnerabilities to both
via fibrosis and to Neoplasia or to cancer.
Tissue repair replaces lost cells.
That's regeneration and it rebuilds lost s extra cellular matrix including the
base basement membranes of the extracellular matrix.
Excessive regeneration combined with oncogenic mutations,
causes tumor growth.
And after the age of about five,
interestingly,
repair of extracellular Matrix produces fibrosis and that leads to scarring.
But that does not happen in children younger than five.
Fibrosis can also lead to a loss of organ function.
For example,
with liver cirrhosis or pulmonary Sark,
sarcoidosis in the lung.
Yeah,
fuel reallocation is essential for managing or physiology and for managing
things like starvation.
But it has Associated Diseases Tho though those diseases,
uh,
elicit costs that rarely had to be paid until modern times.
Fewer reallocation support shifting physiological priorities,
for example,
during infection or pregnancy.
But in the context of obesity and chronic inflammation,
these same processes can lead to type two diabetes.
Our ability to store calories as fat created a vulnerability to obesity when
continuous unlimited food is encountered.
Similar issues arise with dehydration and volume depletion.
We need to be well hydrated,
but the mechanisms that regulate our water content also contained
vulnerabilities.
Homeostatic control of water and sodium is done with endocrine mechanisms that
evolved in environments that were chronically deficient in sodium chloride table
salt,
dramatic increases in salt consumption,
stress,
our physiological systems that regulate sodium because sodium has a key role in
the control of blood volume.
The result has been an increased incidence in hypertension.
We've also evolved defense mechanisms to avoid predators and pathogens and with
of course then to avoid these diseases associated with those pathogens.
We avoid pathogens by detecting proxies of high microbial density,
smells,
tastes,
and sites.
Those are the things we think are disgusting.
We avoid rotten food,
feces and humans who are just suffering from contagious disease.
When exaggerated such defenses can produce obsessive disorder,
so that's the disease of an exaggerated defense.
We avoid predators by staying away from open spaces and unfamiliar surroundings.
That is very useful if you're in a high danger environment like the Serengeti.
Yeah.
However,
when exaggerated or inappropriately deployed,
such behavior can produce Agora phobia.
Yeah.
So to summarize,
the exaggeration of every type of defense produces a characteristic associated
disease.
Okay.
Feed forward loops and positive feedback are part of the design of these systems
because they provide a rapid emergency response,
but those very things create vulnerability to an unmanageable runaway process
like septic shock and embolism.
Okay.
The design of tissue repair makes us vulnerable to cancer in fibrosis.
The design of fuel reallocation makes us vulnerable to type two diabetes.
Okay.
The design of water and sodium control makes us vulnerable to hypertension.
And the design of pathogen and Predator avoidance makes us vulnerable to
obsessive compulsive disorder.
And Agora Phobia.